[Musique]
Je me sens tellement fou
moi aussi je vois
Oh donnez-le monsieur
Jésus
[Musique]
si je dois le casser un peu de plaisir
peut-être que vous êtes venu sur moi Tu me manques
Jésus
[Musique]
Phyllis ne parle pas sue m'a dit
vois pour t'y accrocher Jean ma chérie
medea je te dirai que les Médicis de notre
résidence ne conviennent pas au recrutement Le
commentateur CG est sur Tavano ICI le pour voir
Parvati Mandir dia ray montre Silla fair
rockin wahoo les un bar avec un
démo pratique ici sevate vasila alfalfa - chips de pommes de terre
le velours du ripa repetier
avec ma est une chanson d'amour réduite le Primo
Mears dit cet ampli si longtemps gris vient une
personne à réaliser qui est très très
méduse fa vient ici est mon amour
chanson celle que je ne t'ai jamais écrite je dois le
faire moi-même ne t'oublie pas
voici ma chanson d'amour simplement des mots Malati
à quelque chose comme ma seule façon de
te souvenir nous sommes une scène paisible car mon frère nous nous
serrons fortement ce que
Wyatt ferait même  être dans les dents
nous n'étions pas lâchés le temps n'est pas toujours
mais je t'aime donc j'aime  e toi
alors voici mon fils
[Musique]
Oh
alors voici bonjour alors
[Musique]
oh tellement
connu de toi voici ma chanson de vie quand
le soleil quoi de neuf je n'avais pas de mot tout pour
aimer de nouvelles émotions mais je ne suis pas sûr
voici ma chanson d'amour chantez-la
avant que la nuit ne s'en aille ne vous
méprenez pas tu vas me manquer nous sommes autre car
nous nous avons vu grandir nous sommes tout à fait d'
accord pour ce que ça vaut
blanc bleu jusque dans les dents  nous ne prendrons pas
le temps ce sont toujours Je t'aime tellement
je t'aime alors voici
[Musique]
Oh chanson pour toi voici mon
voici mon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour toi
[  Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]